i feel like of all industries affected
in the last year
like music has been a huge one
especially obviously from the aspect of
performing
so do you feel like you learned even
more in the last year with
rick like taking care of yourself and i
know you said you're still working on it
i mean aren't we all but
um but did you learn anything else
about ways that you can better take care
of yourself so that perhaps
you know world tour coming up exactly
yeah i think it's the first time i've
actually sat down and really
realized touring is so many good things
for me that i
i charge on that so much it fills my
soul
in a lot of different ways there's the
travel aspect there's
i get to do what i love like i get to
play music and i get to actually connect
with people
i get to see what we've done in a vacuum
how it
how it connects with human beings and in
person i read
their reaction when they're singing you
know a song with you on
that's you can feel that you can um and
you can
it just lifts you in such a big way it
just fills your tank and also like
i got spoiled i didn't realize how much
of a deal this was but i got spoiled i
was with like-minded people we're on a
bus with 12 people
i'm with like-minded people every night
i'm going out to my favorite bar which
is the front lounge of the bus
every night and hanging out with my
favorite people after the show there's
so many elements of touring
that um i i think i'm
i'm well number one i'm grateful for but
i'm also grateful
for the lesson that that i've learned in
the last year which is
how how much i love what i do and how
much i love
being on the road and how important that
is for me and it's not just
you know it's not about attention or um
or just you know making a buck being on
the road it's
it's still a passion of mine and i'm
really grateful that
i've gotten to sort of see it while
being without it
you know and and really sit down and and
become aware of the things that are good
for me and also become aware of the
things that when i do go back on the
on the road things that i um that i
could probably do without
or or things i should change about my
daily routine and
um and you know et cetera et cetera and
and there's just you know even separate
of the road just
yeah how to be a human how to
you know i i think i threw myself into
work when i realized we weren't gonna
tour for a while like i
was like all right i'll make an album
i'll finish the album i've been working
on for
two three years um and i would do that
until you know four o'clock in the
morning i'd run myself into the ground i
still do it
i'd still run myself into the ground
yeah oh you love what you do
do you feel like it gave like the album
sort of
sort of migrated a little bit out of
country and into this new you've
i think you've been in la more often
like do you feel like the
sound changed too like was that part of
this transformation a bit yeah well
you know my sound's never been purely
one thing i think if i've
if i've ever if i've ever had a struggle
it's been that i don't
just fit in in one place uh and i think
this was the year that i finally stopped
seeing that as a struggle and seeing
that as an advantage and seeing yeah
good thing and i i i've always felt like
it was a good thing and i've always
instinctually known that i think
um it can come at a challenge when
you're
when you're asked to label yourself as
one thing
um and i think this year was just the
year that i said well i don't really
have to and
and i think people are people are still
gonna get what i do and people are still
gonna
dig it especially if i include more of
of the things that i love
in the music that i make if i don't try
to edit it out
based on my understanding of other
people's expectations but i just give
them
you know all of the influences that i
love if i put all of it together in
a project um and and spending more time
in la was definitely part of that that
was something that was
both calculated and non-calculated we
honestly it
started purely as let's get an airbnb if
we're gonna if i'm gonna
work you know and so hard on an
album let's go to a really scenic place
you know we have a self-sufficient
team i was kind of like let's all be
somewhere we really want to be um and
that turned into me getting a real
estate agent and me
you know acquiring this little studio
compound and um
because i just there's a lot of people i
love working with out there i love being
out there
um i've still got a place in nashville
and i kind of split my time between the
two but
i think being out there also just like
it was a you know a scenery change it
was a visual change and every day that i
woke up i was in
in this new place and um and it allowed
me to
undo those filters and and really
include
the whole the rest of the story well of
course i'm gonna ask
what is that but you said it changed the
scenery but the scenery changes your
emotions
and your feeling and so i'm curious
about what those things were
that changed as a result of seeing
things visually different out your
window
yeah well you know or how did you see
yourself differently
i saw myself differently the the
limiting beliefs that i think i had
that i had um maybe i can't include
all of the other genres that i love or
maybe i can't do certain things with my
musical production
um i also think writing-wise it helped
tremendously
and it also helped too that i was
working with like different producers
and different
people in different um
sort of job title i loved producing and
for some reason
i had told myself that i couldn't i
couldn't produce my own music
and in all actuality i really enjoy that
part of the process
i love collaboration and i think i had
to learn
um or i am learning
that you know collaborations don't all
have to look the same
and you know in the past you know
certain people who do certain
tasks in the in the order of making
music
it's been always very linear and i think
i had to break the line and just say no
i like
i like being involved in this part and i
like giving it away and then i like
being involved in this part
and just learning where where my
strengths play into
what i love to do um it's not that i
have to do all of one thing or
all of the the other thing i enjoy the
collaboration and i enjoy
um sort of the tag team effort of it
so that was one thing that i i learned
from being out there and working with
people out there
and also just working on my own music
you know
i wasn't looking at a wall um the same
wall
working on on production anymore i had a
window with a
view of the mountains and i just felt
like i was in this super scenic like
retreat
so it sort of felt like i was on
vacation making the album
which which undoes is making like a
kenny chesney
like beach chair kind of an album now
yeah not necessarily but and it also
allowed me to fall in love with
you know there's a lot of parts of los
angeles that have a very historic
place in music making i can't tell you
how many times i've watched the you know
sound city documentary and things like
that
um also allowed me to go back to
i really like old music
i say old music yeah i mean you know
whatever
i like older music i love stuff that was
made in certain era it's because
those eras were full of instrumentation
that is timeless to me that
doesn't ever get old we saw it this year
one of my favorite albums of all time
got another swing at life this year
because somebody posted a tick tock on a
freaking skateboard singing you know a
fleetwood back song
and then all of a sudden everybody was
paying attention to my favorite
fleetwood mac one of my
top three all-time favorite albums was
was on like a spotify playlist like
freaking like whatever it was it was on
this like super popular playlist that i
listened to all the time
but here was this super dope old sound
that actually still
sounds new and fresh so i think i just
reconnected with that too like i
want to make music that sounds timeless
and doesn't just
follow trends or just study what's
working and apply that
um i think you already have done that i
feel like i've talked to a lot of
artists and i find it to be such a
redeeming quality within an artist
whether it be
like i talked to moby um mclemore
like some of these guys where you can't
like you it's hard to even put your
finger on exactly what the genre is
because you're creating your own which
to me
says it's really you're really accessing
it from
spirit or from your um your truth
or who you are and that is not something
that's quantifiable that's not
boxable it just is what it is and so i i
i
i admire you for sticking with that and
in fact even like
going in deeper have there been aspects
of the going in deeper that have felt
really uncomfortable yeah for sure
i mean you have to uh honestly last
night one of
one of my friends had a brilliant quote
i don't know if you heard this but
he said you know if you if you want to
have massive success you also have to
have a massive trash can
it's a ridiculous statement but it's so
true like you have to be
my my ratio is like 100 songs to get 10
that consistently it doesn't matter
like i it doesn't matter that i'm
learning how to make
better music or learning how to access
that thing quicker or more efficiently
or be more present
i'm still going to need to write like
three songs to get the point across and
get to the place where and sometimes
it's the first song sometimes you end up
tossing everything that happens after
because you think you can do it better
and then you realize you already did it
more you know
honest um so i think that
you know there's scary stuff it's been
um
trying things and
you know knowing full well
that i mean anything outside of the i
know that this is what people are
expecting from me anything outside of
that is scary